you and I have an anniversary coming up
and this is a true story you were the
second guest on my late night second
second night you are a second night yes
second night I was on the air 1993 so
it's coming up 144 years ago I think we
have a picture of me that's hilarious
we're gonna do a ring in our silver
anniversary Conan we'd like some how you
look okay I look like a little boy
somehow snuck onto a set
well I've got something greasy living on
my head your your head is seemed to like
it's like the plate tectonics like
they're pushing the hills in the new
hair yeah the new hair is being pushed
further and further up and look at that
shitty old apartment I know why did we
do this show in a mustard coat that's a
baby [ __ ] we cover an apartment
I think JJ Walker didn't jayjay from the
JJ was on the show wouldn't know I don't
think so
that wasn't know are you thinking
someone else I'm trying remember what
the set was from yeah I don't remember
it was you that's we were we were
figuring everything out night tonight
back then there's some good times good
times
you